one time I was singing one of my band
songs and the girls in the lab began to
harmonize and uh I sort of discovered
this amazing thing that we could
collaborate not just scientifically but
musically cuz they have just phenomenal
voices sitting here in this room
watching everything move I do not know
how this city was
built
we are
foren the
sound the African trainees are here for
the summer and so we've we've had this
thing where every Sunday whatever is
going on we make sure we take a break
and we come together and we sing and we
happen to be singing the uh the the
weekend after I learned that my my good
friend Dr Khan had become infected with
ebola and of course I was very overrun
with a lot of
emotion the answers in the
star
sky but we were home all along and
we
think um and I was singing with them and
I was still like said I was holding
something inside and I just looked at
the faces of the girls and it lighted up
when with the music and so I wrote this
song it's called one truth and it's all
about um you know our our place in this
world and who we are and and one of the
last lyrics in it it says you know it's
a lifetime for one truth that I'm alive
and so are you we are here we are the
proof and a lot of the song talks about
we laugh we cry the hunger in us will
never
die we dream and we scream and W try the
hunger will never die I'm here in this
fight actually if you go through the
lyrics it gives you that that hope you
know for the future I think one of the
lines that just you know came and I felt
that emotion was I'm in this fight with
you always and I have that sense that
with Dr Khan I'm in this fight with you
always and even now that you've passed
on I'm still in this fight with you and
with every individual who lost their
battle um it was very deeply personal to
me and to be able to share that with
these women who again I I'm connected
with in a scientific Pursuit but also in
this very personal way is just the only
thing that kind of lifts me up in a
really difficult uh period in my life
and in the lives of of the many people
that uh work with
us Life Time the one true the time the
one
true